foreign
[Music]
no running in the Halls
with the Kraken running loose you could
use a bodyguard oh you're sweet the
monster could be lurking around any
corner I fight it for you
can I talk to you
okay everyone else private talk time bye
so
what's up Chelsea about last night I am
sorry that I ranked apologies are so
corny just skip to the part where you
tell me everything look I
you are here on land one day and you
already fit in I've been here all of my
life and I still feel like a freak
I just want to be Ruby Gilman normal
teenager oh where's the fun in that Ruby
you're a giant Kraken don't you think
you could aim a little bit higher than
normal teenager
oh my cute little floppy baby guppy girl
you know what you need great hair in a
mermaid tail
no but it would help what you need Ruby
Gilman is to see how great your life
could be you need
okay
let's do it yay
just four more days until prom the last
evening of Joy before entering the
drudgery of adulthood
[Music]
it was all fun and games
[Applause]
[Music]
this thing's been amazing I mean Seven
Seasons seven hours and don't get me
started about how wrong they got the
crystal jellyfish in the marine
biologist quarterly sorry am I geeking
out too much no
thank you
can't believe your mom hid all of this
from you hiding is surviving that's the
Gilman family motto mottos are stupid
that's my motto I hate hiding but you're
crushing it at school everyone loves you
you really do have everything no I don't
ever since the battle of the Trident all
us mermaids have been in hiding I
couldn't take it anymore I felt trapped
so I ran away
but when I ended up at Oceanside High I
was alone
no one could see the real me
and then I found you my super sea girl
bestie and now everything is right in
the world if it wasn't for this whole
mermaid versus Kraken War you and I
could be this free all the time oh sure
yeah but I mean two teenage girls can't
fix history
wait what's the first rule of being
athlete never talk about being a
mathlete no we have to evaluate the
problem Chelsea come on there must be
some way to end this war so you won't
have to hide from the Krakens and I
won't have to become a prophecy Princess
Warrior of an interspecies Vendetta well
there is one way
marine biologist quarterly oh Ruby
you're still reading this trash humans
don't know everything about the ocean
mom there's a whole world down there
that I have never seen jellyfish
Plankton coral reefs but what else lives
there I know monsters and those monsters
want to hurt Krakens like us this is
where we belong Oceanside is our home
then help me fit in by letting me go to
prom Ruby the answer is no
[Music]
let's all have a very human day does it
bother you guys that we lie to everyone
all the time oh we're not lying we're
just omitting yeah okay I remember
anyone else we're from Canada
Connor's here uh yeah Connor's here
oh
oh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh oh yeah Connor we
are all like polygons all right team
Mass we'll see you later you know it
anything for my algebra you're what now
I mean oh algebra like you're my brother
you're my math brother
the first one better
Connor are you okay yeah it was crazy I
just remembered I was saved by the new
girl the new girl
the new girl
thank you thank you
going to say something
picture this me stunning but
approachable on my first day of school
I'm lost and confused struggling to find
my first class when suddenly I spot
little Mr skater boy here barely above
water I'm just lucky
my story now I'm not much of a swimmer
but in that moment I remembered what my
mother always told me you are gorgeous
also big risk big reward always go big
and what is bigger than saving a life
[Music]
I love you
love you too Rando she pointed at me I'm
random this isn't just any party this is
prom and I really want to be a part of
it we all do yeah no I get it you guys
should go without me it's one thing for
my mom to ruin my life she doesn't have
to ruin yours uh what if you don't tell
her yes with exclamation dragon's right
your mom doesn't have to know deception
I'm on board come on do it do it I want
to but if my mom finds out oh life is
not a dress rehearsal it's time for you
to go big and
okay okay okay
you're right
okay I'll do it
I'll get a prom yes
yes your special Ruby you feel it in the
core of your being
let me teach you but my mom told me that
if I stay out of the ocean I won't turn
into a giant Kraken you you are not a
human who turns into a kraken you're a
kraken hiding as a human
once you know what you're capable of
you'll want to be the next Kraken Queen
it's your Birthright and fight as you
might fight as you will you can never
outswim your destiny
wait is that the new girl oh my gosh hey
Chelsea how are you even down here
because I'm a mother flipping mermaid I
figured I owed you an underwater rescue
since I kind of sort of 100 about credit
for yours time for the garden special
surprise it's a bomb
oh we should get going or like die your
call we are here in DreamWorks preach we
are recording Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken
and I play room oh hey Ruby is a 15 year
old girl and she's very normal oh hi hi
hi hi but her secret is that her and her
family are actually cracking
our family is kind of living undercover
Agatha turned her back on that world and
her mother and my grandmother's a queen
oh Warrior Queen I never thought in my
wildest imagination I'd be playing a
kraken I'm very proud to be playing the
Kraken call me Grandmama and the Bad
Girls of the ocean are the mermaids
thank you oh it's so much fun to be bad
you're just a dumb teenager
this movie is very much a coming-of-age
story about a young woman
stepping into her power and finding out
who she truly is the message is so good
like your differences is what makes you
so unique life is not a dress rehearsal
it's time for you to go back
and I just found out that I'm gonna play
the first female Title Character in a
Dreamworks Animation so it feels really
cool
DreamWorks guys it's a big deal and it's
just fun I mean I loved reading this
story and watching it evolve has been
lovely to be a part of I feel really
honored to have done this project has
been nothing short of an entire blast
it's kind of amazing
[Music]
thank you
your mother never told you you were
royalty the women in our family have the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now Ruby you're a princess aggress
the crowd
I think
I am having a panic attack
okay Ruby have you completely totally
ordinary day you got this
[Music]
thank you
I feel like a freak ow I just want to be
Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
who are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
see what you're capable of
body armor laser
almost
it's time to go big
uh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh
anything for my algebrae do what no I
mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother you know I think I like the
first one better
[Laughter]
[Music]